Tom Tom Cruise Tom Tom Tom Cruise Tom
town
Tom Cruise Tom Tom Tom Tom tuck tuck
tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck
Tucker Tom Tom Tom Tom Tom Cruise Tom
Tom Tom Tom Tom Cruise
[Music]
[Applause]
Ethan
what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here jonald we just got back from
Mission Impossible fall out people
shouts out to a couple of people who
recognize us over there Chris the main
guy I'm not sure if your friend Dale
recognized us hey Chris how you doing
buddy speaking of shouting people out
patron of the day shout out for a man
named Michael Burnett he has an awesome
youtube channel called Omni media
there's a link in the description box
for you guys it's another movie talk
channel he does like reactions reviews
as well but the guys knowledge is so
in-depth like the guy clearly knows way
more than us and if he keeps at it he's
gonna be on his path to being a huge
YouTube or seriously you guys should go
check his channel out it's amazing and
just from talking to him and messages
he's just a super nice guy he's a really
friendly guy and I'm really happy to
know him by the way on our patreon we do
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is a music video coverage so go check
our patreon out after this video if you
liked our onto our movie review wow this
has got to be the most disappointing
movie I've ever seen up worst of the
year worst of the year man all the
Razzies oh that's my phone dole there's
no excitement in it no action Harleen
yeah it's so much CGI everything was
shot on this really small frame yeah
like a 4 by 3 leading up to watching
this movie i benched 1 through 5 because
I hear this one kind of ties things in
more than the other ones tend to and it
does I won't spoil anything speaking of
spoilers I would avoid the second
official trailer for this movie because
it ruined way too much yeah yeah way too
much being on the first trailer there's
some direct action sequences in the
first trailer that are not in this movie
that doesn't matter cuz yeah this movie
is spectacular spectacular action
sequences we watch this on IMAX and
there were two specific sequences that
were they filmed it with IMAX cameras
and even the ones that aren't in IMAX
shots are still breathtaking Oh
everything is top-notch and just how
much hard work and craftsmanship and
attention to detail goes into it all its
really well captured and there are just
so many different kinds of action set
poses that all look really authentic and
also clicked a lot of practical effects
yeah really do more stuff and yet
is a really impressive feat of just
stunt you know grounded action
everything those trailers and the
marketing and the behind-the-scenes T's
for the stunt sequences they all live up
to the hype I'm telling you the halo
jump scene is amazing the helicopter
chase scene incredible Tom Cruise
running is as you know his boggers Randa
is on foot chase scene in this movie
when he was going I just smiled like I'm
just I'm so happy you do this hey I
actually just felt happy watching him do
this JC yeah point during each you know
a Mission Impossible Tour date where he
busts out the hit single they have on
the map to begin with yeah one thing I
also appreciated about this movie is
that while the action definitely
delivers there's just as much of a fight
going on with the espionage elements
like the amount back and forth and and
mystery there is and like things going
wrong like I really appreciated the
theme of this mission it seemed to be
just how many ways can this all go wrong
and what clever ways can even in the
team adjust to them definitely this
movie's more of a direct sequel to the
previous Mission Impossible
more than any other ones I've kind of
handled its continuity I really feel
like to really appreciate it understand
this movie you have to have watch rogue
nation that works to its benefit unlike
say Quantum solace I think in terms of
what an action movie is I'm not sure yet
I got digest it a little bit more before
I put my ranking out there for where I
put this but I think it's pretty easy
for me to determine that in terms of an
action movie
this Mission Impossible does it the best
not only is it bigger they all escalate
and you get more action than the other
ones - yeah and each action sequence has
different sets of sakes like it's
intense enough just watching them do
what they're doing but also the context
around it what's at stake like oh yeah
it really rings in this movie I kind of
feel like the big highlight action
moments in the last couple ones
sort of occur in the middle of the movie
and by there they kind of you know
simmers down here up until the finale
it just gets crazier and it's different
types of sequences man it's brilliant
and the other thing I really love about
this film - my favorite Mission
Impossible I would have to go with part
three only because of the fact of how
emotionally thrilling it is now personal
it is and how much you really get to
know and feel and love Ethan
in that movie I've kind of feel like
rogue nation and ghost Protocol missed
that element a little bit in terms of
really knowing Ethan Hunt and loving him
I kind of feel like when I watch ghost
Protocol rogue nation I walk away with
thinking of how cool Tom Cruise is this
one brought me back to I love the
character Ethan Hunt it's a good point
it's gonna be kind of impossible to get
as personal as part three did at one
point Tom Cruise says mi6 and he's
referring to the bridge spy but I'm like
you know this is a also say fallout yes
so this is the second most personal one
it makes everything feel that much more
suspenseful I'll say though that this
movie I don't think in terms of the spy
stuff
it's as necessarily clever as maybe how
some stuff was handled in rogue nation
for example like I think the finale of
rogue nation is brilliantly done in
terms of spy outwitting each other
elements this one is more of a
straightforward action movie with some
clever moments there are definitely some
clever moments in here it's just not as
clever
yeah it's a lot more about what doesn't
go according yeah and then what does
yeah it's like then the movie starts off
you're like wow this is a lot of
information about what this missions
going to be but then as it progresses
it's pretty simple to follow yeah dials
back a lot of the humor that was
presented in Ghost Protocol and some of
that in rogue nation yeah it's a much
more serious film there's a tonne of
danger definitely and that also serves
to work stages like I wasn't really sure
who would be safe in this that's what's
missing too and ghost Protocol and rogue
nation for me in this movie I'm like oh
my god they're gonna kill this person
off yeah you started thinking this and
of course you know like a big thing that
everyone was really looking forward to
is Henry Cavill in this movie the
mustache was worth it and I thought
Henry Cavill did a pretty good job in
this film you had a great look in the
film I'm like okay I can't wait get the
money worth to the character I feel like
there's so much hype towards Henry
Cavill in this that I thought he would
have been cooler yeah I'm gonna try to
dim it down for you if you haven't seen
the movie yet I feel like the whole
group that we were with kind of felt
that way of we thought we walk away be
like Henry Campbell stole the chef
buddies
yeah he's really good and he's effective
in the film he's not as badass as you'd
expect him to be his performance is not
as cool as you'd expect him but it's
good it's effective oh yeah I don't want
to make it sound like I'm talking bad
about his performance he was something
that I was curious about going into this
movie and when it started off I was like
yeah I like him all right and then
partway through when his character
really starts to become important I dug
it like I dug what he was doing with it
yeah yeah I like it I do like it I just
love it I also think the supporting cast
in this film did a really good job - I
thought they utilized everyone that you
see brought back in the trailer really
well the first trailer reveals Michelle
Monaghan is in here he's barely in the
movie but when she's there it's
effective it's more than just cameo
greatest if the supporting characters in
this film I thought they were handled
really well I don't want to give
anything away but there's a really
emotionally effective moment that came
from Ving Rhames in this movie Luther
yeah that I didn't see coming at all it
was the one moment that really actually
got to me and it's those nice surprises
like that and also it's a personal
mission what he's doing why he has to do
it I think it's revealed in the trailer
of what this mission is they're going on
and why in case they didn't I don't want
to mention it that's a missing
ingredient that I felt is missing from
the set up of four and five is the setup
here is immediately personal which makes
it all the more rewarding the other ones
can feel kind of like episodes and I do
think there's something about this one
there's something about part three that
having that personal touch just it makes
the stakes more resonant for the whole
ever yeah you know and I like to that
this movie bothered to give other
characters some personal stakes it's
just in small ways in details it's not
like a character stuff Benji or
something like that everybody has a
moment to be a real person in this movie
that's what that was a nice day bring it
all together and to make it feel human
in Solomon Lane returns in this film
he's really effective Rebecca Ferguson
is great again Simon Pegg is funny but
he's still good he was more even much
more on the intense side in this film
he's still a valuable member of the team
and Luther - and Vanessa Kirby's a new
character in this film who I had no idea
what her role would be or what her
performance would be like and I thought
she was really effective she was she was
charming and Alec Baldwin when he's on
screen he shines and Angela Bassett is
in a couple shots and there's a really
killer score in this film
one thing I've really appreciated since
part three is I feel the score and all
the films have been great and this one
has a really great dynamite score lorne
balfe however there's a couple of scenes
all the sequences involving in the Paris
that you see where he's like on the
motorcycle there's a whole there's a
little chase sequence going on
it sounds straight up from the Dark
Knight Rises
Leon Zimmer just sprinkled some it
sounds like The Dark Knight Rises song
and then suddenly it's the Mission
Impossible tune and then back to the
Dark Knight Rises songs like they took
the Mission Impossible music and then
just swept a Dark Knight filter on yeah
that might not be a distraction for you
for me it was kind of a distraction it
works for the movie but you're just
automatically transported to that yeah
if you're watching I remember watching
The Dark Knight Rises on IMAX it's cool
I thought this was a tight action spy
thriller for sure I don't know yet where
I drank it I will say though regardless
it's an amazing installment in the
franchise oh yeah if you like action if
you like espionage if you like stunts
yeah you know like I think you're gonna
have a great time with this regardless
because it's it just seems like it's
firing on all cylinders yeah I don't
know where I would rank it necessarily
but I think it doesn't matter yeah it's
just a really well-made action espionage
movie and that's good enough on its own
you know I've always appreciated the
work Tom Cruise is done for these films
I had a moment where I was like I am so
grateful for the hard work he puts it it
really hit me of I am just so grateful
for how committed you are to these films
just to entertain an audience yeah yeah
yeah he's really doing happy things like
even if not half like 95% of yeah it's
like even if he's strapped on to
something like he's still up there like
you know at the heights and dude yeah
yeah I'm like you're getting as close to
being an action hero as I guess you
could be yeah thanks man and watch on
the biggest screen you could possibly
attend yeah it's dynamite go go check it
out as soon as you can yeah that's
easily Terry Cruz's best Ethan Hunt
easily well even though we can't rank it
where would you rank fallout put it in
the gun boxes you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Milka subscribe button suck
please check us on patreon we put a lot
of work into our patron out with
plenty maybe more over there than we do
on YouTube these days please go check us
out would love to have you become a
patreon object today